speaking of presidential did you want to
talk about Bernie is that your first
thing I have a thing up there but I
didn't research enough but I'll talk
about it just quickly so a bunch of
people on Twitter were freaking out
because Bernie's proposing this tax on
vested shares that you haven't actually
cash to him yet okay and tech people
were like okay there goes the startup
scene like what you know if you're on
vested shares that they haven't actually
received the prop like this company's
not liquid and so there are some nuances
like it's written here it's taxed on non
qualified stock options of at least a
hundred thousand you know if you have
over a hundred thousand in stock stock
options that are vested and your and
employees making at least one hundred
thirty K so it's not everybody and it's
not all types of things so it's not RS
use its ISO as I believe okay so I'm not
an expert in this stuff at all and I'm
not an expert in politics I know what I
believe but I don't know the technical
Depot well let's agree to talk out of
our ass for talks I'm not gonna talk
about that actually but here's what I am
going to talk about is starting a
company and how it worked with us in
this wool a lot because I do know that a
lot of people think like oh the rich are
doing this they don't understand things
so when we started the hustle I saved up
twenty five thousand dollars to start it
with that twenty five thousand dollars I
made sixty grand in profit in six weeks
which is pretty good and the first year
in business was roughly three hundred
eighty thousand dollars in revenue and
most of it was profit because I paid
myself we were in I think we were in LLC
I would through two thousand dollars a
month in salary salary and that's why I
paid my bills my rent was cheap very
cheap hundreds of hundreds of dollars a
month and I lived off $1,200 beyond that
beyond that I was very I lived very very
very frugally and then we decided to
raise a little bit of money I raised I
think three hundred thousand dollars
from people at a three and a half
million dollar valuation you had to
change from being an LLC at this point
right yep changed an S corp I think it
was an S corp probably C course I don't
remember I see this is I'm not an expert
in this yeah you want to be a c-corp if
you're gonna take investment that's just
like you don't have to study all the
differences between them but if
gonna take like traditional investment
they're gonna want you to be a c-corp so
we converted it costs five grams to do
that at this point we probably had half
a million dollars in the mmm $300,000 in
the bank account
I don't remember between 300 and 500
thousand by the end of our first year
and we raised money at a three and a
half million dollar valuation and then
once we started doing stock options and
stuff like that we sign up to Carta and
they gave us a let's take all the 409 a
yep where we got so that for nine a just
values your company at some numbers yeah
you guys had revenue so they probably
took some standard really value to us
and you want it to be low at this stage
yeah so they valued us in the millions
of dollars of range I don't remember it
could have been three and a half it
could've been six I don't remember the
number whatever these types of
businesses are that's what they've done
you want it to be low because that's
what your share price is that's what
your stock options are gonna be if
you're an employee you want to get in at
the sort of low valuation so when it
sells at a high valuation you get this
sort of increase in value but if they if
the 409a comes back high then you're not
gonna get you know as much of a lift on
your share and so at this point our 409
a is many tens of millions which is nice
that's cool we have a valuable business
but when we started it was single-digit
millions which was still a lot I was 24
at the time I said I started with
$25,000 and I was taking $2,000 a month
I was not saving any money right okay
I'm not complaining because it worked
out but so on paper I was a millionaire
multiple millionaire if I had to pay I
think there I forget what this I don't
want to like act like I know I'm talking
about I let's say if I if I had to pay
20% in taxes on that multiple millions
of dollars you wouldn't have had I
literally wouldn't have had any money to
do it right even if I wanted to withdraw
money from our business account I would
have had to lay people off or right like
so when people say such certain people
are hoarding money or something like
that a lot of times it's not true and I
have a lot of founder friends that have
businesses that are on paper worth
hundreds of millions of dollars right
and they have tens of thousands of
dollars saved that's a bank account yeah
so they're not liquid are you
I think people need to and this also
happens if you're an employee you leave
a company you usually have what they
call an exercise window which might be
30 days 60 days 90 days I think that I
think the normal 90 days so that gives
you three months to come up with the
money to buy your options or you lose
them yeah and a lot of people don't have
that money cuz like you know they leave
one company it's a startup and now their
shares are worth 80 grand or 180 grand
and they need to go they want to go to a
different job and now that you need to
come up with an 80 or 180 grand to buy
out their options and that's not still a
guarantee that that money's coming back
and often people don't have that money
sitting in the bank
so they'll forfeit their options which
is a true bummer some companies are
being cool about it Pinterest a couple
others I don't remember movie stripe
they increase their exercise window to
seven years or six years so they're like
look we know this practice a little bit
crazy it's hard to come up with that
cash and you worked here you earned your
shares so we're not gonna try to take
those back you have the longer window
because we might be private for longer
which is kind of a cool trend so when I
dub company should do that my w2 income
so at this point I make money in 8 or 10
different ways I got loads of things
that just it just has added up over time
and that's great and I still pay myself
a salary I pay myself not that much I'm
not the highest paid person here yeah
and I but my w2 salary we're gonna be
four years old I've been working on this
as a project since it was a 14 we're
gonna be four years old officially in
April I next month I my w2 salary and
year one I think was $24,000 a year to
maybe thirty six and then year three
then I started going higher right
because the business was established
yeah but my w2 income historically has
been low right quite low and so when I
saw this and I saw people getting mad at
rich people I'm like I bet people
thought I was rich you know yeah and you
wouldn't have qualified for this because
it says you have to be making at least
230 K but like what if I three years at
tax on my stock now it would be painful
hard yeah you'd be in a really
tough spot so you know Bernie I like
Bernie
this is a little bit crazy this will
really screw up the way the startup
ecosystem works but it can also adapt
I'm not even gonna shake ass today and
if I think it's crazy or not I just
didn't giving a perspective of my
business and I bet and I think I I now I
think I have a lot more cash than even
most people who have companies that are
huge
[Music]